une grande qualité vous pierre c'est si
votre ouverture au monde des femmes
c'est vrai oui je sens que vous allez
oui savez quoi
oui je sais je serai grand oui on va
faire une interview transforme et je
m'adore abouti bien dans le père vous
êtes une femme oui d'accord d'accord
oui c'est tellement pourri ailleurs vous
appelez comment je m'appelle alzheimer
yens ah ouais ouais d'émilienne me
viennent si jolie emilie elle est jeune
c'est bien ça fait moins cher émilienne
oui émilienne si je lis misait il vous
plait pierre arditi en plus fort les ag
caen
c'est monstrueux donné une carte il me
donne une carte pour revenir c'est bien
tu as nouveau slogan c'est monstrueux ça
va rester cinq mois
les milliers il vous plait bien arditi
royat pire hein c'est pas parfait mais
il ya pire les vous savez pas
sérieusement oui je savais pas qu'il
fait un peu vieux beau quand même n'en a
sûrement oui en tout cas vieux sûrement
bouchet pas messieurs vient aussi beau à
6,6 vieux vy emilienne oui oui mon grand
est ce que tu es une femme facile non
non couchés quoi le troisième soir c'est
pathétique
alors qu'on peut garder celle là c'est
pathétique comme ça c'est bien ce qu'il
faut le dire parce caméra c'est assez
pathétique de la lingerie ça vous plaît
messieurs à oui vous avez quoi comme la
dga sachez là j'ai un truc qui remonte
un peu en balconnet parce qu'évidemment
touche à sa fin comme vous l'avez très
justement fait remarquer je ne suis plus
le de la première messe mais pas mal oui
enfin bon vous a permis de vous faire
refaire les seins et médiane pas trop
non seulement contre mairie du merisier
vous faites quoi emilienne écouter
absolument rien de temps en temps quand
même je me regarde dans là je me dis que
peut-être devrait finir par monter tout
ça
wes enlever ses plis puis au bout d'un
an je dis non yahia là le petit garçon
de la jeune femme qui a fait les
magnifiques éclairages de la pièce qui
est absolument adorable kiev deux ans et
demi ce qui ressort d'une maladie assez
grave et qui en revient à la vie
maintenant qui est venu sur le plateau
pendant qu'on répétait et était
absolument divin il a sauté sur le
plateau il a commencé à sauter et moi je
faisais attention parce que j'ai
toujours peur qu'ils tombent alors il va
rentrer la dia et je laime bien lui il a
dit à sa mère je les aime bien il a dit
le monsieur qui est un peu abîmée c'est
mon copain ça m'a beaucoup plu
c'est pourtant d'indiens rien que pour
ça je voudrais pas me faire refaire
vous préférez qui me viennent sur ce
plateau c'est un endroit on n'élimine
pas donc j'élimine pas mais si tu
dégages virer un seul mais c'est ce
genre de questions qu'on lui pose est ce
pas choisi gérard pour toi je désirais
quoi toi aussi suite les choses il avait
mal à jouer c'est moi qui prend ce but
allait bien au chaud au pot pour la nuit
je choisirais dès qu'il apprend la messe
à céret qui je suis hétéro mois